or uh Tony
uh where'd you grow up where are you
from originally Southern California
um in the Inland Empire
all over the Inland Empire moved around
a lot as a kid like Riverside Santa
Bernardino Riverside San Bernardino
Fontana yeah
um I spent a couple years in New Mexico
ended up moving there when I was around
15 and I also traveled back and forth uh
every summer so have some roots in New
Mexico as well what was your uh
childhood like with your family
um my childhood was pretty good from the
outside looking in
um
had some things going on in my childhood
that would eventually lead me to a
sexual addiction a drug addiction
alcohol addiction
um
but these are things that I that I've
done a pretty good job of keeping
bottled up in fact some of the stuff
that I'm going to talk about today I've
never openly talked about with anybody
but from the outside looking in it was
good what was your relationship like
with your mom and dad uh mom and dad a
quick backstory on them they uh they met
while my father was locked up my mom
started writing him letters uh once he
got out they got together at a young age
like 17. but they ended up divorcing uh
when I was one so I never actually saw
my parents together
but I've always had a great relationship
with both of them I always say that I
grew up on both sides of the fence
life with my father and life with my
mother were two very different uh
experiences uh which was it your dad was
the bad one my dad was uh the devil and
one shoulder and your mom was the angel
yeah something like that my dad was a
great father not not to get that you
know misunderstood but I could get away
with a lot more with my father I
experienced a lot more with my father my
mother was was more strict
um
she monitored what I watched what I
listened to where I was she knew my
friends she knew what I was doing at all
times kind of tried to keep me in bubble
wrap so to speak
I've heard you in school
say again how far did you go in school I
graduated high school never went to
college I joined the military right out
of high school I was in the Navy for two
and a half years I was supposed to be in
for four
but I did two and a half years ago
stayed out of trouble in the military in
the High School in High School uh no
high school is where trouble started for
me um what'd you get into
a lot of partying
um a lot of sex a lot of sleeping around
um experiment with drugs cocaine ecstasy
Molly
um
growing up most of the men that I was
influenced by in my family all served a
significant amount of time in prison
gang members drug dealers so
at one point in my life I thought that
that was the route I wanted to take I
thought that that's what I needed to be
in order to be respected in order to be
a tough guy so I I dabbled in that area
never joined a gang but I got into gang
activity
um
stealing breaking into places I
shouldn't have been fighting things of
that nature never went to never went to
prison
[Music]
and then I
so in your 20s you got you did some time
no no no never never once a person I've
been to jail I've done some overnighters
but never went to prison oh I see okay
and then tell me about your 20s
20s
um
20s was uh was wild I was I was doing a
lot of drugs I was
um I was partying a lot kicked out of
the Navy and that had a lot to do with
my sexual addiction and my alcohol
intake that got me kicked out of the
military
um kind of just lost in my 20s didn't
know who I was didn't know what I wanted
to do with my life bouncing around a lot
from
um living situations to jobs
just really trying to search for myself
and uh trying to figure myself out
getting through the addictions but the
addiction started uh
at a much younger age
what do you think the addictions the
worst of your addictions were
um
I would say
I would say the sexual addiction was was
the strongest one
um but that
is what brought in the drugs and the
alcohol and then it all was just
intertwined and
um there's two particular things in my
in my childhood that I think uh brought
me there that you know amounted to that
what do you think happened in your
childhood
the first thing I would say the
foundation of a lot of my problems a lot
of my insecurities a lot of um you know
I had I had a major wall built up at a
young age I had a stepfather came into
my life when I was three
and um he was a bully he was he was
abusive verbally and physically
um he would he would always call me a
little boy don't do that little boy he'd
always point at me don't do that little
boy don't talk to me like that little
boy
and he would punch me Square in my chest
push me down to the ground he did this
thing where he would pull my ear and he
would pull me all the way down to the
ground and then he would dig his knee
into my side and he would scold me that
way throw me around
but it was what made it worse is that
you know I had to walk on eggshells with
him there was times where he was really
cool there was times where he played the
part well the the loving stepfather
but in any moment that could change and
obviously had some issues of his own and
uh and I was the one he took it out on
so at a young age I I became very
insecure very timid uh didn't know how
to make friends
um it didn't help that I moved around a
lot as a kid I went to a couple
different elementary schools two
different middle schools three different
high schools so making friends was
always hard and um
just didn't fit in as a young kid got
bullied got jumped on the way home from
school things like that I mean a parent
like that is so destructive for our kids
it is self-worth it is it is yeah I I
must have felt like I couldn't do
anything right
um I remember growing up I always had
good ideas I always had good thoughts I
always had a good input but I never let
it out because I had no confidence no
confidence as a kid whatsoever
it didn't help that I was getting
bullied at home and at school so as a
young kid I just completely shut down
and then things started to change for me
around 15 years old
once I was
15 all right well the thing with my step
dad that stopped around 13. um
you know I always wondered you you hear
this often with kids that are that are
abused at home a lot of times you hear
that they don't say anything they don't
speak up and um I think personally it's
because either they're afraid of the
outcome or they just don't know that
their situation is a situation you know
if you know he was my stepfather since I
was three and that was all I knew so
maybe I didn't necessarily know that I
had a shitty stepfather until I got
older once I was 13
I finally told my dad and I think around
this age I started to realize who my dad
was my dad was was a thug he was a tough
guy not to be messed with and so I
finally told my dad what was going on
and I don't remember if he called my
stepdad personally or if he called my
mother but he said the next time you put
your hands on my boy I'm gonna fly to
California and I'm gonna kill you
and um that was when it finally stopped
the abuse for my stepfather
and then when I was 15
I decided to move out of California and
go live with my father in New Mexico
um
I think I was ready to have my dad in my
life every day there was things that I
needed to be taught I needed to be
taught how to defend myself how to fight
how to work on a car you know things
things that your father should should
teach you
and uh because when I was getting
bullied in school and bullied at home I
I wasn't a fighter and you know I was
more afraid to fight I didn't I didn't
want any any issues
um so when I was 15 moved to New Mexico
Las Cruces New Mexico
to live with my father
and at this time I was I was a good boy
I was curious I was always curious
because my mother kept me from things
you know I wasn't allowed to see certain
people in my family I wasn't allowed to
stay the night with certain cousins
um I wasn't allowed to cuss I wasn't
allowed to watch movies with sex or
cussing I wasn't allowed to listen to
music with cussing
and so I think that always made me
curious for those things you know so I
was curious but I was a good kid I
didn't get in a lot of trouble yet at
this age I was a virgin I had no plans
on having sex yet my mother told me at a
young age that if I had sex before
marriage I'd go to hell and and I
believe that that's what my mom told me
and I believed it so
she put the fear of God in Me and had no
plans on having sex until marriage but
when I was 15 I was living with my dad
and this is when the the second most
significant thing in my childhood
happened
um
we had a neighbor that lived next door
and there was like four young girls a
brother a mom and a dad and they were
all my age we were all you know 14 15
years old and
um and we would play with these these
kids you know we go to the house all the
time we're always at the house this is
who we played with on the Block
um
and we were curious kids we would play
Truth or Dare stuff like that make out
in the closet things like that but
pretty innocent for the most part
one day I
walked over to the to the house to see
if anybody was home knocked on the door
and the mother answered the door and
later on in life I found out that she
was actually an illegal immigrant she
barely spoke any English but enough to
get through a conversation but very
choppy
and um she said nobody's home but you
can come inside and you can wait if you
want
um until the kids get home
and that wasn't strange you know I I was
at this house every day the mother would
cook dinner for us and stuff like that
so it wasn't strange
so I went inside and as soon as I walked
in the door there's a couch to the right
so as soon as I come in I sit down on
the couch and
she says why don't you come in my room
and wait with me
so I said okay
so I got up and walked into the room
with her and she said don't you sit down
on the bed with me
and at this moment I realized that this
is getting a little personal so I
remember my heart beating out of my
chest I was nervous I knew something was
off
but I was curious about it and so I sat
on the bed and she turned on the TV and
and it was a full-blown
hardcore pornography film and at this
age I had seen magazines Maxim magazines
Playboy magazines but I've never seen a
porno like this before
so she introduced me to that she turned
it on and uh just started watching it
with me she asked me if I liked it I
said yeah I like it
and um
she said why don't you lay down
so I laid down on the bed she got down
off her side of the bed walked over to
where I was and she started massaging my
shoulders my chest my legs
and then um she stuck her hand down my
pants and started to massage me and uh
she asked me if I liked it and I said
yeah I like it
and uh
she uh she pulled my dick out and she
started giving me head and that was the
first time that I've ever felt that ever
experienced that and I remember being
extremely nervous but
I liked it it felt great and it was the
first time I experienced any of this
um
I wrote about this situation in a song
I want to share the lyrics with you
before I continue on with the story I
said
I said I was 15 she was 36 I give to her
my innocence this filthy [__] put a
filthy flick put a silky lips right on
my dick admittedly I was nervous I never
felt this I like it I love it she [__]
me I'm ruined she is selfish a rotted
seed planted by the Devil Himself for
this seed would grow like weeds
contaminate to oneself forbidden fruit
forbidden you forget to spit out this
pitiful you bit the sweet deceit
discreet defeat is at your feet
satisfaction grasp it quicker than a New
York minute stupid you consumed up in a
switch and meet your doom within it hit
your knees hold crucifixes too
suspicious who can fix this I'm a
nuisance plead forgiveness hit my knees
right after she did
that's the only time
that I've ever spoke on this situation
it's an older song It's a song I put out
when I first started making music a lot
of people haven't even heard this song
um
but to get how old are you now
33. so you carry this with you all these
years yeah
I think for a long time
I just uh
pretended like it wasn't a big deal
it wasn't until much later in life and
I'll get there in the story that I
realized wow I can't believe that I went
through that and didn't think it was you
know a big deal
um so she uh she said I don't have time
right now
um the kids and my husband will be home
soon but I want you to come back later
tonight and I'll let you in the back
door
and I'll show you more
so I said okay so I came back that night
my husband was gone he worked nights the
kids were all asleep and she brought me
into the back door and um and she showed
me how to have sex I lost my virginity
to this woman she was 21 years older
than me she showed me how to have sex
she showed me different positions she
showed me how to penetrate deeper she
showed me how to please her I think that
was that was her main objective to teach
this this young boy how to please me and
um
and uh
I became addicted to that feeling
everything I felt that day you know
imagine being a 15 year old boy a good
kid a virgin hadn't seen pornography yet
or nothing like that and all in a matter
of 20 minutes I'm introduced to all of
this and uh she opened up that door
you know for the devil to come in and
and uh he didn't just come in quietly
busted down the door and came in with
friends you know and um
so that was the start of my sexual
addiction I I wanted that feeling all
the time I thought about sex all the
time I became addicted to pornography
um I remember living at my dad's house
we didn't have uh internet we didn't
have Wi-Fi I had a PSP a PlayStation
Portable
and you could use the internet on those
things
we didn't have Wi-Fi but the neighbor
across the street did so I would sneak
out in the middle of the night and I
would sit in front of the neighbor's
house and steal the Wi-Fi to download
pornography
and um even worse than that uh you know
we lived in the desert there wasn't a
lot
in Las Cruces yet it was a lot of just
open desert and when we were kids we
would walk through the desert looking
for snakes and lizards and stuff but uh
I started to find porn magazines
scattered throughout the desert
everywhere
and my only guess is that they were left
behind from homeless people
and uh so after a while I would stop
looking for lizards and snakes and I
started going into the desert just to
collect these magazines and I'd bring
them home and keep them
dirty magazines left behind from
homeless people and I'd go looking for
them and bring them home and keep them
that's crazy
um so porn addiction
um
sexual addiction and
what I experienced that day
was forbidden fruit is the way that I
like to explain it she was married she
was 21 years older than me
she was the mother to my friends
and and I had to sneak around you know
to have this relationship with her so
everything about about it was forbidden
and so as my sexual addiction grew it
wasn't enough for me to just have sex
with women I wanted something forbidden
I wanted that chase I wanted something I
wasn't supposed to have and that
that ruined a lot of relationships a lot
of friendships I've I've slept with
friends girlfriends friends wives
um friends sisters sisters of sisters my
sisters friends
a lot of married women
are forbidden relationship's the only
ones that interest you
no I wouldn't say the only ones but it
was definitely what made me feel that
adrenaline again that Adrenaline Rush
that I was that I was searching for I
had you know regular relationships but
those ones made me feel different
uh I think it
somehow made me feel in control or or a
sense of maybe revenge or or Empower
empowerment
um
I yeah I was I was addicted to to the
chase I guess you can say
um and just having something I shouldn't
have had
and then um
like I said the the sexual addiction
um
that started to introduce alcohol and
and drugs because it was all intertwined
you know alcohol I learned at an early
age that alcohol
broke down that wall for me it it gave
me confidence it gave me courage it
allowed me to be sociable it allowed me
to be funny everything that I wasn't
before I thought for for many years for
for a decade I thought that you know
alcohol was my friend alcohol made me
into the person that I wanted to be I
thought I wanted to be
but I really just had a wall built up
and
um
alcohol was was not good I I've I've
been in so many situations where because
I was the type of Drinker that would
black out
most of the time I drink I blacked out
I've woken up in bed with women
completely naked and not knowing how I
got there that's happened many times
I've
I've gotten to fights and uh broken
people's property punched holes in walls
a lot of anger would come out when I
would drink and that was that was what
led me to to get kicked out of the
military to
um
I joined the military right out of high
school
and went to Thailand twice
and the first time I went to Thailand I
I had been drinking all day
and by the end of the night I left the
club with a female I would assume she
was a hooker of some sort she wasn't
from the ship she was a Thai girl
and I left the club with her and went to
another spot the spot that she took me
to was a two-story building and the
bottom floor was a bar and the top floor
was was a whorehouse
and
um you know while everyone else on the
ship was doing fun things like kayaking
and rock climbing and stuff this is what
I was doing I was chasing uh chasing
women you know
um
some of the story is a blur uh but I
remember enough to tell it I remember
drinking on the on the first floor with
this woman and I remember following her
upstairs and when I get upstairs this is
where I black out something must have
happened something must have set me off
made me angry or scared
um I remember being in a room a small
room and I was trying to get out of the
room and I couldn't get out the door was
locked I couldn't find a way out and I
remember just being in a complete rage I
was throwing things in the room I was
breaking things I was punching holes in
the wall couldn't get out of this room
finally I found a window
and I busted out the window
and um
stepped outside the window and now I'm
on the roof I'm on the roof of this this
uh this building
and then as I start walking across the
roof to get away I fall through the roof
the entire roof just collapses
and I fall down to the first floor
and um and then I black out again and
the next thing I remember being arrested
by Thailand police and escorted back to
the ship
and when I got to the ship and then this
you know they sent me to Medical I was
all scraped up and bruised and
um when I started to sober up I told
them right away I said I want to be drug
tested I want to know if I was drugged I
want to know what happened and they
wouldn't they wouldn't test me they
wouldn't drug test me they just wrote me
off as a drunk mess and and that's it so
still to this day I I don't know the
details of that night
but chasing women and alcohol is what
got me there
luckily the Navy didn't kick me out
after that they gave me a chance they
sent me to anger management through the
military they sent me to AAA through the
military
um they put me on restriction I was in
the military for two and a half years
and for six months of that time I was on
restriction I was always in trouble
because of alcohol
restriction means I had a badge with a
big r on it and I couldn't leave the
ship it wouldn't matter if we were home
in San Diego or if we were out in
another country I couldn't leave the
ship I had to stay on the ship do extra
Duty stuff like that
so after I did my anger management my
AAA all my restriction a year later
we're back in Thailand again
and because I did you know I finished
all my punishment I was able to go off
the ship but I had to be back at a
certain time this time
I didn't come back I didn't come back to
the ship I found myself with uh women
again Thai women
um
this time I got a hotel room with with
some friends and we brought a handful of
hookers to the hotel room and and had a
big orgy recorded it all that video is
probably floating around somewhere I
don't know
um and I was supposed to be back on the
ship and I stayed out
so when I finally did return to the ship
they had enough with me and this was
what finally sent me home so I got
kicked out of the military
and um
when I went home from the military
I
finally decided that I wanted to settle
down and finally decided that I wanted
to be with one woman and try to relax
stop the drinking stop all that
and and I got slapped in the face
um
I met a girl at a restaurant I was
working at
and
um any relationship that I had ever been
in prior to the relationship I'm in now
started with sex all my relationships
started with sex that's how they started
so I met this girl at a restaurant we
were working together we started hooking
up and
um we were together seven months she got
pregnant and I was looking forward to
being a father I was ready to settle
down I was going to use this as
something to be responsible for and and
to you know have a bigger purpose in
life than just partying sex so uh we you
know we told the whole family everybody
was was in tune with what was going on
we were going to have a baby
and um you know we had some issues a
matter of fact right right before she
got pregnant we had broke up uh just for
a short amount of time and in that time
I was already sleeping with other women
and she found out so that was really
hard for her to accept
she calls me up one night when she's
pregnant and we're expecting the baby
and she says I'm getting an abortion
tomorrow morning and there's nothing to
do about it and that was the last time
that I ever seen or heard from her so
slap in the face you know I finally
tried to settle down
and and do that whole thing and it
didn't work so then
that's when I started doing drugs that's
when I started doing cocaine uh Molly
Ecstasy uh
partying stopped working for months
slept on my mom's couch I was a bum
and the sexual addiction grew stronger
I
I at this time I got into like meeting
women on social media and
um
I I would even meet women that lived out
of state out of California and I would
get them to fly to California just to be
with me for the weekend
and and that was my thing you know I
found enjoyment in that
um just partying and sex partying and
sex drugs alcohol
I was lost for a long time my mom would
come home from work and I'd have a woman
on the couch my mom would come home from
being gone for the weekend and find me
in her bed with another woman
it's a it's disgusting it's
disrespectful
you know and and that's the behavior I
was doing
um
and then my mom finally had enough of
that
she uh she kicked me out and I went to
go live with my dad at this time he's
not in New Mexico anymore he's now in
Apple Valley California so I went to go
live with my father
um and at this time in my life
I
again was trying to clean up I was
trying to be sober I was trying to stay
away from women and
um you know throughout all this I I've
never seen a counselor I've never talked
to a therapist nothing I've tackled this
on my own my entire life just between me
and God I believe in God I pray a lot I
was raised in church so that's something
you know that my mom put in my life at a
young age
and it's just been me and God the whole
way just a lot of prayer a lot of uh
trial and error a lot of failure
um
but I never gave up on myself at this
time
I started to have this voice in my head
and and and God was telling me
I have something special for you but you
you have to get clean you have to be
sober and you have to stop chasing women
and and that voice was so strong man
every time that I'd go out and do my
thing the next morning when I woke up
hungover
I heard that voice you got to stop I
have something for you I have something
special for you but you got to stop you
got to get clean
and I battled with that for years
and then uh and then I met a woman who's
my wife now and um
she was the most
pure woman I've ever met she was she was
good she she was not like any other
woman that I had ever had a relationship
with and I knew that right away and I
knew that this was part of you know what
God was telling me and for the first
time in my life I was
I guess you could say forced to fall in
love with a woman without sex my wife
was a virgin when I met her and and I
had no intentions on taking that from
her
um so we we were in a relationship and
and we fell in love and we built a
friendship and that was the first time I
ever experienced that so 10 years after
this woman showed me how to love
sexually
I meet another woman who shows me how to
love
without sex and and I needed that that
was that was what changed a lot for me
and
my wife she came into my life and she
helped me with my sobriety she helped me
clean myself up
and
now we're married we've been together
nine years we're married we have a
five-year-old boy I've been sober from
drugs for five years I'm still on my
journey with alcohol
um I've
it's I make it to like a year sober and
then I I have a relapse you know at
least once a year it's been like that
way for the past five years but I I
could honestly say I haven't been drunk
in five years
but I I slip up you know and I'm still
on that Journey but I I do plan on
living a sober life from alcohol and
um you know this year I'm picking myself
up and and making that attempt again
um but
um
somewhere in there where where I met my
wife and I and I and I did get clean at
one point in my life I was completely
sober for two years
and during that time is when I found my
passion and my talent for for music for
writing music I'm a hip-hop artist I'm
an independent hip-hop artist I've been
making music for five years as soon as
my son was born and I found myself
through sobriety and through prayer
I just
prior to when my son was born I had
never wrote music I had never tried to
be an artist myself I had
I mean nothing at all you could ask
people who I grew up with people from
school
never at all
and once I was sober and my son was born
Rhymes just started coming through my
head my mind was filled with Rhymes all
the time all the time I was rhyming in
my head rhyming in my head
and um
and I started to pay attention to it and
then one night I was laying in bed I
couldn't sleep and I had these Rhymes in
my head I pulled out my phone and I
started writing my notes and at that
moment I realized that that God put
something special in me that I couldn't
see for years you know most most artists
uh most successful artist hip-hop
artists you hear their story they've
been doing it since they were 15 16 20.
it was never like that for me and I
realized now it was because I was I was
distracted I I couldn't see anything in
front of me because I was distracted I
was chasing women I was drunk I was on
drugs and as soon as I let all that go
I found what was inside me and I'm a
phenomenal artist I I have a special way
with words with lyricism storytelling
and uh I believe I have a future ahead
of me in music and and I'm right in the
middle of it right now
and um I would have never found that if
I didn't find sobriety if I didn't let
go of my addictions if I didn't
um break that wall down naturally
because alcohol broke that wall down but
I had to break that wall down on my own
how are you emotionally when you were
going through that that period
oh I mean being a young teen and then
meeting your wife
um
like throughout the entire process the
sex addiction the alcoholism emotionally
um
I mean it sounds like fun for a lot of
people right yes yes that's a great
Point uh you know there's people that
will listen to the story and say you
know 36 year old woman at 15 that sounds
like a great time but for me I always
wanted better for myself and I knew that
these things were toxic
um and and I hope that I can be an
inspiration and a message to other young
men especially today because in the
world we live in today sex is everywhere
and it's accessible
when I was 15 I had to go out and find a
porn magazine or or watch a porn on TV
but today it's on your phone just pick
it up it's right there right there in
your reach for little kids too for
little kids too yeah and I I would like
to be that message uh to let young men
know that it's it's toxic it might seem
enjoyable it might seem
you know that was I think that was part
of my uh problem through all my
addictions was why should I not have
this if I enjoy it I enjoy it why should
I not have it but sometimes things that
we enjoy are toxic for us
and sexual addition is is very toxic
especially pornography at a young age it
gives you a false reality of what a real
relationship should be like
it takes away from your natural
confidence and and your perception on
what life really should be like and what
a relationship should be like and I had
friends throughout my entire life that
did the things I did and and were
totally okay with it that was their
lifestyle but for me I was always
different I always had this voice inside
me that said you need to do better this
is not good for you you need to do
better and um and when I finally
listened to that voice and I let go of
all these toxic things in my life I
found my passion in life I found out
that I could write music I mean I I
can't stress enough how incredible when
I when I realized how talented I was
with writing music it was it was
emotional I cried I couldn't believe it
coming from a kid with no confidence
a kid who would never step on a stage
and and tell his story or or sit behind
in front of a camera and tell his story
um
I wasn't I was never great at anything I
wasn't great at sports it wasn't great
at anything I was just mediocre my whole
life and when I realized how well I
could put words together and how well I
could write music and rap it was
incredible it was like it was like I
found
a Hidden Gem inside me and and now
hindsight I know that it was always
there because I was always infatuated
with rap music with music I was always
infatuated with lyricism and and I would
study artists and I would study their
story and I would watch their their
documentaries and I was much more into
music than anybody around me
so it makes sense now now it makes sense
and and at an early age I would write
little poems for my mom stuff like that
and now it makes sense it was always
there it was always there but I couldn't
see it
and it's almost like the sex addiction
was just a distraction that kept you
from finding it absolutely
absolutely
yeah that uh you know overpowered
anything else that was in my life I I
was chasing that Adrenaline Rush that
that feeling that made me feel good
coming from a child who was abused at
home bullied at school no confidence
to now being able to please women
because that was the thing for me I I
didn't it wasn't that I needed to be
pleased I wanted to please the woman
that was that and that's what she taught
me you know and so through my sex
addiction it was about me pleasing a
woman I want to make you feel like
you've never felt before and that made
me feel some type of way
Tony what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in all
of this
it's uh
it's always been
me versus me you know I could I could
blame it on my stepdad I could blame it
on her but it's always been me versus me
I always had the angel on my shoulder I
always had that voice in the back of my
head I always had the desire to want to
do better
and and I was fighting myself the entire
time
I was fighting myself the entire time
and you you just have to reach a point
where where you're done beating yourself
up and you have to take control you got
to sit in the driver's seat and you have
to take control and find a way to be
disciplined find a way to be the one in
control because it's you versus you your
situations in your life may affect you
and they may cause you to do these
things but you're in the driver's seat
the whole time
the whole time it's nobody else's fault
but yours it's nobody else's it's in
nobody's hands but yours
and if I could do it anybody can do it
and I'm I'm certainly not against
therapy or or having a counselor or
anything like that but I've never had
one never had one it was always me and
prayer and just just paddling myself and
and I got through it I'm happy now I'm
sober
I have a beautiful wife a beautiful son
I live a good life and in this life as
fun as that life sounded all the women
all the partying
did I enjoy it during the time of course
I did
but I'm so much happier now I'm happier
now I'm complete
and
I'll take this life over that life any
day
excellent story thank you Tony thank you
so much for sharing it thank you for
having me good luck with your music
thank you